JOINING US AND WHAT THE CHICAGO
PD DO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Laura: WENT ALL RIGHT.
>> THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY THAT
WE HAVE UNDER OUR ALTERNATIVE
PROSECUTION UNIT THAT IN
EXCHANGE FOR THE COMMUNITY
SERVICE AND BOND FURNITURE, THE
CASE WILL BE DROPPED.
>> Laura: SHE LOST HER VOICE
AND THE INTEGRITY.
HOW DOES HE GET A SPOT IN THE
ALTERNATIVE PROSECUTION LINE
QUITE LIKE YOU ARE RICH, YOU'RE
AN ACTOR, AND YOU SHOW THE PLUGO
BELIEF OF THE STATE ATTORNEY WHO
DID NOT FORMALLY A CRUISE      R
DID NOT FORMALLY A CRUISE      C
DID NOT FORMALLY A CRUISE      S
DID NOT FORMALLY A CRUISE      E
HERSELF
JOHN FROM BERKELEY AND FORMER
BUSH JUSTICE DEPARTMENT FOR WHAT
YOU THINK ABOUT THIS?
RAHM EMANUEL SUDDENLY
>> AMERICANS MYSELF INCLUDED ARE
OUTRAGED BY THIS, THE FACT THAT
THIS GUY FAKED A HATE CRIME.
LOOK, I'M A MINORITY.
YOU ARE A WOMAN FOR WHAT IF WE
WERE TO BE ATTACKED LEGITIMATELY
AND NOW WE ARE GOING TO BE LESSB
AND NOW WE ARE GOING TO BE LESSL
AND NOW WE ARE GOING TO BE LESSE
AND NOW WE ARE GOING TO BE LESSD
AND NOW WE ARE GOING TO BE LESSB
AND NOW WE ARE GOING TO BE LESSY
POLICE AND PROSECUTORS BECAUSE
OF THE EXAMPLE OF THIS GUY.
A LOT OF AMERICANS REALIZE
SOMETHING OUGHT TO BE DONE TO IT
SECOND, THIS IS WHY WE HAVE U.S.
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
MAYBE THEY SPENT A LOT OF A LOT
OF TIME IN THIS GETTING'S
INVESTIGATING PRESIDENT TRUMP TO
NO GOOD EFFECT, BUT THEY NOW MAK
NO GOOD EFFECT, BUT THEY NOW MAE
NO GOOD EFFECT, BUT THEY NOW MAS
NO GOOD EFFECT, BUT THEY NOW MAR
NO GOOD EFFECT, BUT THEY NOW MAE
THERE'S NO CORRUPTION GOING ON
IN STATE DEPARTMENT.
WHERE MRS. OBAMA'S CHIEF OF
STAFF BECAUSE THE PROSECUTOR KIM
FOXX AND ALL OF A SUDDEN THESE
MACHINATIONS OCCUR AND THE CASE
GETS DROPPED?
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT IS SUPPOSED TO BE
INVOLVED IN IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE IS NO CORRUPTION IN STATE
GOVERNMENT.
SO I HOPE THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
IS RIGHT AND THE FBI ARE
STARTING A INVESTIGATION TO LOOK
INTO THIS.
>> Laura: WHAT'S THE POTENTIAL
CRIMINAL EXPOSURE HERE BOTH FOR
FOXX AND THE STATE ATTORNEY
ITSELF?
>> FOXX MIGHT BE
IF SHE IS CONVICTED, THIS IS THE
STANDARD LAW THAT USED TO GO
AFTER CORRUPT STATE OFFICIALS.
SUPPOSE SHE GOT A BRIBE, SUPPOSE
SHE WAS PROMISED A FUND-RAISER
OR SOME KIND OF OTHER INFLUENCE
TO DROP THIS CASE, THE MAXIMUM
SENTENCE IS 20 YEARS IN PRISON.
>> Laura: WHY DO YOU THINK
RAHM EMANUEL TOOK THAT TURN?
>> THIS TAKES A CONSPIRATORIAL
MIND-SET.
NOT SURE IF I HAVE THE RIGHT
ONE.
BUT CHICAGO POLITICS, THESE ARE
ALL PEOPLE WHO ARE
INTERCONNECTED.
THEY ALL WORKED IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION OR ARE WORKING
FOR THE OBAMAS NOW.
LOOKS LIKE THERE IS NOT SOME
SORT OF PRESSURE DEAL TO MAKE
THIS ALL GO AWAY.
>> Laura: ALSO SMOLLET
HIMSELF, DOES HE HAVE ANY
EXPOSURE UNDER FEDERAL CRIMINAL
LAW?
>> HIS STORY IS NOT OVER.
EVEN THOUGH THE CASE UNDER STATE
LAW COULD BE DROPPED, HE COULD
BE PROSECUTED UNDER FEDERAL LAW.
HE USED THE INTERNET -- AGAIN,
MAIL AND WIRE FRAUD, TO ENGAGE
IN A CONSPIRACY TO DEFRAUD,
NAMELY THE PEOPLES ENGAGING IN
CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS WITH, TO
DEFRAUD THE PEOPLE OF CHICAGO,
THE PEOPLE OF CHICAGO.
PLUS HE DID THIS CRAZY THING
BEFORE WHEN HE MAILED HIMSELF A
CHEMICAL WEAPONS.
HE MAILED HIMSELF A WHITE
POWDER, CLAIMED AT ANTHRAX,
TRYING TO REPORT BACK TO THE
POLICE.
THAT'S ACTUALLY A FEDERAL CRIME,
TO CREATE A HOAX.
>> Laura: I DON'T THINK ANYONE
UNDERSTANDS THIS UNTIL YOU SAID
THIS.
I DON'T THINK ANYONE ON
TELEVISION HAS DISPLAYED IT THAT
CLEARLY BUT THIS IS NOT
UNSERIOUS STUFF.
THIS IS NOT LAUGH ABOUT IT --
ISN'T IT FUNNY, THAT LIBERAL
ACTOR -- HAS TO MAYBE PAY
$130,000.
WHAT DO YOU DO.
>> I DO NOT THINK MICHELLE OBAMA